So, those are the best tips I can give you on how to give a presentation.
Any questions?
How can we figure out if we have distracting mannerisms or not?
You have to practice in front of a mirror, watching yourself speak.
What about telling jokes or anecdotes during a presentation?
Is that OK?
Positive jokes are appropriate for presentations.
A good anecdote could be helpful for explaining your point in a presentation.
So, if it helps the clarity of your point, I think an anecdote is fine.
Do you prefer scripted presentations or do you leave room for spontaneity?
Usually, the text from my slides is enough.
I don't write everything.